What's up guys? We are back again in the beautiful
Arizona desert once again with the Sonic Dad Team to test one more experimental idea.
[and] we've got a glass jar. Some aluminum foil and [the] drain cleaners sodium hydroxide
We're going to mix these [two] together with some water and producing hydrogen gas with that chemical reaction started going to take this 36 inch
Balloons put all the top capture that hydrogen Gap tie it off
And then we're going to shoot it with this modified round [out] the sparkler in the end
We're going to see what happened when we like this and stick it in the cannon
We should be able to hit those hydrogen balloon and cause a big ball of fire least
That's the idea [and] [I] got a request from tuna bug to make some kind of a flaming arrow
So I thought with the sonic Dad team there's no more perfect opportunity [that] what we're about to do today
You guys remember how this works, we're gonna
Take some drain cleaner fill up a glass guard and put in some aluminum
And add a little water is going to create a reaction that generate hydrogen gas
We're going to cap it with the balloon and collect all that gas in the balloon
And I brought some stick welding gloves because this jar is going to get extremely hot
Jake why don't you take this you can just go ahead and Sprinkle in a bunch of sodium hydroxide and so [this]
[yeah], aluminum seems to be the limiting factor. So we're just going to put in more other than less
That's going to be enough to fill up our balloon
Alright, let's get some water
Not going to be an immediate reaction that should take off here in about 30 seconds now just watch
Look at that reaction that is amazing
[it's] bubbling at least three-quarters of the way up the jar, and [I'm] sure that's getting extremely hot right now
Lets take it off. That's hot. It's very hot
Yeah
Check this out it floats got a boomerang balloon
So there's about two minutes after it captain. Go ahead and feel that
Yeah, that would be hot to the touch gloves [if] you [don't] want to hold that very hot right now particularly. Yeah, that's
what I heard in 10, maybe
It's very warm right now when the hydrogen is flowing into the balloon
It's actually very very hot and as we cap off the balloon and it cools down the gas shrinks
And so our ballon's quite a bit smaller than we started It used to float as well
And now it's not floating as much, and that's because the density of the rubber is pulling it down, but this will still work
There's still quite a bit of hydrogen here at least enough to get a good reaction. I think
You hear that it's all water splashing around inside there. That's the theme condensing and turning back [into] water inside the balloon listen this
That's why it's not floating. It's got all that water in it. It's spilling down my gloves. It's probably not good
And it smells like hydrogen
It smells like success
It smells like we're about to have victory here in the Arizona desert
If I open the neck of the bottle a little bit, you can see already the condensed water is starting to drip out cool
Alright update our hydrogen balloon
Is that all we have to do now is light up one of our sparklers are shove it in the barrel and send it flying
[let's] see if this [actually] [works]
My slow-mo's rolling Rich is gonna let me take the first shot
Yeah, fire in the hole
321 00
that was
nice yes, that was amazing. So I couldn't have asked for anything better to hear that won't call that hydrogen just coming out
It wasn't exploded it was almost there was a big ball of fire
but I still felt the question [would] you feel that your chest so
I was like a spacey, sud
Cool
Now this is h 0 gas that would have been explosion would've been here piercing
But because hydrogen it had to [fuse] with the oxygen as it burned and so it probably took about 10 times longer for that burn
[and] if we use [h/o] so apparently hydrogen exploding targets on our thing. We're going to make it again and again and again
We're also adding a little bit string here because as the balloon
Inflates the hydrogen is lighter than air and so it may want to float away
[ok] let's get these things lit up. [I] don't think we have a lot of time to work with there. We go. We got him
Fired [didn't] ignite. [I] don't know if that blew up or not
Now here's the thing guys are theory on why that last one didn't make a big fireball is because the hydrogen was Mick 16
When the Sparkler [when] there's a lot more heat energy that had to dissipate through the steam and so did make a big fireball
Wow, that was actually a lot
like blast back for my face
And I think [about] [5%] [we're] all good. That was hot I thought that on my knuckle. It was awesome
Good no doubt here guys let's roll
[yeah]
rise look at that reaction
Bueno Bueno indeed
This way we can watch it from a [distant] and my hands are burning
[now] just explodes [as] a whole lot of steam in my face a lot of hot gas starting to get a little tighter
I think I'm going to go ahead and release it release the kraken
ready the cannons
Ok here. We go on three two one fire
[321]
Little bit of a delayed reaction there, but I heard [that] I thought up that camera might have [thought] a real close
That was good. That was a good amount of hydrogen. I feel very happy about selling the grand Council approved as a graph
So it looks like igniting Giant hydrogen targets as a team effort
Cool there you have it guys epic day of experimenting with Sparkler bombs and hydrogen Target. We had a lot of fun doing huge
Thanks to the sonic Dad team if you have not checked it out yet
I've got a link down in the description you can click to go to their [channel]
[I've] also got a link to the plans for their original Marshmallow cannon you can download it and try to [hold] yourself
And a big [thank] [you] to bug for suggesting flaming arrows and help make this experiment happen today
I got [twenty-five] bucks [come] your way. Thanks for joining us for this experiment today. We'll be looking for the next video documentary
blown up balloon
with science